Cuáles son los datos más recientes que
se conocen sobre los misiles y este
presunto ataque
bueno se habla de dos misiles que según
una fuente de inteligencia americana
hablando bajo el anonimato pues habrían
estado fuera de curso
rusos y cayeron pues sobre una granja
que se halla 5 millas de la población
polaca más cercana a la frontera con
Ucrania pero que se haya también esa
granja polaca afectada que murieron dos
personas en el ataque a 10 millas de la
población ucraniana más cercana a la
frontera con Polonia entonces según la
Fuente americana pues fueron dos misiles
rusos que según lo que él dijo
habrían pues perdido el curso claro hay
otra otro informe no sé si un periodista
polaco que ha ido allí al lugar de los
hechos y dice que los restos parecían de
un misil ese guión 300 que son misiles
antiaéreos de largo alcance el
periodista po sugería que pudo y
pudieron haber sido misiles ucranianos
que pues al derribar o ser el lanzados
para derribar a misiles rusos se habrían
desviado otra versión sería que los dos
misiles que impactaron la granja habrían
sido los restos o misil en fin los
restos de misiles interceptados por las
defensas antiaéreas ucranianas no
olvidemos que el ataque ruso fue masivo
unos 100 misiles lanzados sobre todo el
territorio de Ucrania pero claro vamos a
decir que si fueron rusos los misiles
habrá una investigación partiendo yo de
la premisa suponiendo como el analista
americano inteligencia sugería que eran
misiles rusos para que hayan sido dos
que se hayan equivocado del curso yo
diría pensando malamente que fue un
ataque pero esa es mi opinión de de los
rusos para ver cuál sería la reacción de
la otan que van a hacer y sin duda se
van a reunir mañana miércoles citando el
artículo 4 que cada miembro de la otan
cada uno puede convocar una reunión de
los otros miembros para pues discutir un
tema de alto de mucha urgencia así que
bueno Ese es mi especulación Si fueron
misiles rusos dos que se hayan desviado
por error me parece bastante pues
demasiado error que uno se haya desviado
Pues sí pero dos así que esa es la
cuestión veremos qué ocurre que que se
dice la investigación pero no sería
no habría que excluir Perdón la
posibilidad que esto haya sido
deliberado por los rusos que lo niegan
sí sin duda niegan muchas cosas como sus
crímenes de guerra y que lo hayan hecho
para ver la reacción de la otan y como
una provocación a ver qué hacen Qué
hacen ante esto le compramos a ver qué
pasa no habrá una sí de comprobarse que
Rusia estuvo detrás de este hecho qué
repercusiones se producirían
Bueno hay buena pregunta una fuente creo
que de la otan ha dicho que sería cauta
la respuesta una opinión de un polar con
ciudadano Pues sugería que Podrían haber
más sanciones de las que hay Aunque mi
opinión eso realmente no impide que
Rusia lleve a cabo su guerra habrá que
ver mi mi opinión Pero es una opinión
atrevida sería que upolonia debería de
desplegar patrullas aéreas de casas de
combate para derribar todo misil crucero
ruso o misil táctico ruso que lancen
contra la margen occidental del río
ñeper para así impedir que haya un misil
accidental que accidentalmente cruza el
territorio de Ucrania en el oeste del
río ñeper a Polonia y claro Así
defenderían también la ciudad de
ucranianas pero esa sería mi sugerencia
tiene los aviones para hacerlo hay que
ver si tiene las agallas para hacerlos